nathan drake is making his playstation 5
debut in the form of an uncharted 4
remaster and chloe and nadine spinoff is
along for the ride these new versions
feature three modes fidelity which runs
at 4k at 30 frames per second
performance which runs at 1440p at 60
frames per second and performance plus
which runs at 1080p at 120 frames per
second however for this video we'll only
be taking a look at fidelity and
performance and comparing them to the
original games on a base ps4 for more on
uncharted make sure you like this video
and subscribe to gamespot
[Music]
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
flights in bangkok that um are
having troubles with them because
they've smog and they can't
land
wow all right i'm sorry no it was
valiant i was in the ballpark right
in a different state but yeah you were
in a ballpark
jameson asked you about that malaysia
job again jameson always asked me about
the malaysia job
look nate i really think that you should
take it
you know what i don't want it
really yeah i mean he doesn't have the
permits
and we agreed we're not going to take
that kind of work anymore it's actually
not worth it it
it doesn't sound that risky
all right if it's just a permit no way
you could call sullivan
you haven't seen him in two years could
we please drop this okay i just don't
want you to not take it because of me
i'm not taking it because of me okay
i appreciate the gesture it's just
i'm gonna go ahead and do the dishes
just stop i'll do it no you did them
last night no you cooked i cleaned it's
fine
i mean
at least at least uh let me let me try
to earn it or something let me uh
play you for it
you'll play me for yeah yeah yeah your
little tv game thing i bet i can beat
your high score
you think that you can beat my high
score on my tv game thing yeah i think
you're scared now you don't even know
what it's called i don't need to know
what it's called i've seen you play it's
jumping and running and i have a natural
talent for that so what do you say
chicken is it a better
tree bridge fell
can you make it across
working on it
i'm fine by the way
all right
that should do the trick fraser move
it's an ambush [ __ ] take cover
thanks for the heads up
shoot them
okay we're clear
right
where were we you were about to pull
down an ancient gate
and there we go
you're awfully quiet
i'm just surprised
figured you'd be more of a lead no trace
type when it comes to indian roots
center mentality in this line of work
get you killed
nathan
what are we gonna do with you
you must be tired of these lectures i
know i'm tired of giving them
and now you have to stay here with me
all weekend instead of going on their
treat with everyone else
i don't care
yes that is the crux of the problem
i don't see why i'm the only one being
punished because you started the fight
you wouldn't give me back my book
i told you to leave those books in your
room
you only have yourself to blame doesn't
give him the right to just snatch it
from me does that give you the right to
start throwing punches
it wasn't just about the book
what was it then
nothing
i'll save it for confession
no matter what i try
you seem insistent on going down the
same sad road as your brother
what a waste
sam
[Music]
that's when it's my favorite it makes
you guys doing good
does it now
half price if you buy two
wow
you again
is this your store
no
my father's
how much
800 rupees please 800 rupees
okay okay for you 550.
incredible
so
does your father usually leave you here
alone
no he's always fighting the devils
[Music]
you